the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I'm going to talk about alternate
consensus mechanisms and there's a bunch
of them and sort of some of them are
berry and some proof work some of them
are proved mistake all these different
things so unique node lists this is
something that ripple and stellar use
I'm not sure if there's others proof of
stake is like this huge research topic
that lots of things fall under there's
lots of variants one of them I'll talk
about is delegated proof of stake proof
of space is an interesting thing that is
basically a form of proof of work that
doesn't use CPU as much there's the idea
of directed acyclic graphs which iota is
a great example of and then one that I
sort of came up with a few years ago and
it's kind of fun proof of Idol which is
sort of chilling but silly - so okay and
so sort of disclaimer I'm okay with
proof of work so like I think if you if
you were at the class on Monday it's a
great sort of segue into this we're
clearly proof of work has I don't if you
want to call it problems but like it's
kind of crazy right the all the stuff
David was saying on Monday it's not in
egalitarian you know and I think in the
Satoshi white paper he sort of says one
CPU one vote well that's not really how
it works
there's even if you define CPU maybe you
have your own CPU someone else has a
different CPU and there's you know that
huge industry of building all these
chips so there's a lot of issues with
River work it's certainly not ideal
that's probably not why most people
don't like it so I generally in academia
in a lot of business places people don't
like the Bitcoin proof work mechanism
not everyone but but it's a pretty wide
spread like oh Bitcoin is bad because it
uses as much electricity as Denmark or
something and I think that's the sort of
early I don't like it because it uses
electricity there's other reasons not to
like
which I think you have to go into much
more depth like with David's talk
yesterday sure it uses a lot of
electricity but it also uses a lot of
fabrication plants and it uses all these
other sort of distribution networks so
anyway I get that there's a lot of you
know one of the first things with
Bitcoin is okay how can we improve upon
this how can we get rid of this huge
energy sink on the other hand I'm sort
of okay with it right like i-i've been
the first thing that I thought about
Bitcoin is wow this is gonna be huge is
it gonna take a lot of electricity but
it's kind of cool that it works that way
so I'm sort of okay with people you know
if like to me like you can't really get
mad at people doing things you think are
stupid because you'll just get mad all
the time like people mined gold people
spend billions of dollars on diamonds I
think diamonds are really stupid but hey
you want to dig up diamonds and yeah
there's entire cultural areas that I
just have no interest in okay
okay so I'll try to explain these other
methods in a neutral way but I do have
my own sort of biases where I think like
hey prove work pretty much works I think
it's a cool system and I'm somewhat
skeptical of various different
algorithms and mechanisms here and so
I'm you know I'm and also I'm most
familiar with the proof of work system
and all the sort of intricacies of it so
like with David's talk yesterday like
there's some new stuff but I sort of
knew because I talked to these people
for a long time I'm like this is how
this system works proof of stake I've
seen it implemented in altcoins
but I haven't followed them that closely
so I don't know as intimately like what
goes wrong and all the weird details
anyway okay so the first one UNL or
unique node list this is essentially the
consensus mechanism used by ripple and
seller for history ripple started 2013
they know 2011 I don't know it was
awhile ago
20:13 okay but the comp well the so
actually the ripple eyed the the name
ripple and the idea of sort of these
debt obligations through this network
was actually predates bitcoin and then
jedd McCaleb started the company he's
also the guy who started mount GOx
so he started mount Cox I believe in
2011 or 10 late 2010 sold it to Mark
Karr fellas started Ripple
hired a bunch of people sort of got
fired from ripple a lot of bad everyone
fighting because like you know it was
all these people who used to play Magic
the Gathering and like we're friends and
now they're not friends anymore and it
sucks and then he started stellar which
he called secret Bitcoin project and I
was thinking of joining it but he
wouldn't tell me what it was and and I
also it was like I knew that other
people knew what it was like my friends
and if they weren't telling me because
they're not supposed to it was like well
it must not be that cool because nobody
can actually keep a secret if it's
really cool so so that was my sort of
like I'll just go work somewhere else
and steller was more or less a copy of
the ripple code which was open source so
it was totally fun to do this and then
it sort of diverged and they added their
own their own sort of different parts of
the consensus algorithm than ripple did
so it's a count basis somewhat like
aetherium transactions have sort of
senders receivers what's interesting is
in the stellar case and possibly rippled
there's a minimum balance so I actually
had some stellar last year up until last
year because I went to the sort of
initial release party and they gave out
stellar and I had I had some and it was
like then it wasn't much but then last
year I looked it was like oh this is
like 200 bucks worth I'll sell it and I
sold it got some bitcoins but it was
weird because they enforced a minimum
balance which seems like weird to me
because you you had to retain some
number of stellar
units in every account which to me seems
like sort of weird because that means
like those accounts those the sellers
haven't really there they're sort of
gone in a way in that if you open a new
account and it must have 50 stellar in
it forever will still are effectively
destroyed it just seemed like I mean
which is a fine thing to do it's sort of
a transaction fee but from a computer
science like database standpoint it's
like why not just have it cost money to
create a new account instead of have it
so so these are sort of you know just
interacting with it's like so there's no
work but the idea is that nodes sign
transactions that they've seen every one
sort of makes blocks and you sign them
so you've got some kind of identity your
node has a key when you when you start a
new node you've got a public key private
key pair you can sign off on
transactions this is not the case in
Bitcoin right in Bitcoin you have a full
node your full node might have a wallet
associated with it with public keys and
private keys but the node itself does
not possibly in the future there's bit
150 I believe which the idea is to have
encrypted communications between nodes
which would have some kind of
authentication
there's 115 bit 151 one I might have
them backwards 151 I believe is just
encryption so for privacy sort of
confidentiality and then bit 150 is for
authenticity so you connect to a node
you were like oh this is the same node
at the same IP address that I connected
to before they're not implemented yet
that I'm aware of so right now in
Bitcoin when you connect to people you
sort of just use their IP address you
don't really know who they are there's
no authentication there but in these in
ripple and seller you do know okay I'm
connecting this node it's got a key it's
got an ID in it so to sync instead of
verifying all the work you verify the
signatures on blocks and the question is
whose signatures right so if you assume
okay well if we have a majority that's
honest and is not trying to you know
create transactions that are invalid or
something
that then it might work but majority is
hard to define when you're subject to
civil attacks right the obvious attack
is I just make thousands of nodes or
maybe these nodes don't even really
exist I just make thousands of key pairs
have them pretend to be nodes in my own
sort of sub network and they all endorse
blocks that are different than the rest
of the network is endorsed it so
majority is the tricky part how do you
know who is the majority with you don't
know who these people are you need some
kind of way to identify humans or
computers even and this is a problem
akin to certificate authorities and I
just wanted to sort of so they a lot of
the problems that you see in like block
chaining Bitcoin these kind of things
are not exactly new problems and have
sort of already been quote-unquote
solved so does everyone you know how
ca'se work or do people have some idea
or who's like what's a CA okay so it's
kind of interesting um I can give a
little demo
yes no this doesn't work hold on okay so
if you have a computer I don't know
where that isn't Windows but I think in
Mac and Linux it's in the same place you
go to act and then shoot I forget where
it is where yeah where's the
certificates sir
[Music]
there it is okay so in your computer and
whether you have Linux or Mac you've got
a folder somewhere ET c /c h
certificates something like that in Mac
as well and oh no that's not it
where are they wait wait wait what is in
update dot d and then there's nothing
there hold on I need to find this is
kind of cool
we are X ah
SSL yeah there we go
okay so sorry ET c / ssl and then you've
got certs and this folder has a bunch of
sirs I trust all of these entities well
my computer does and by extension my
browser's and my computer which is crazy
because Turk just really trusts turkey
but there's okay stop there another
let's Netherlands somewhere there's a
bunch of you know things you've never
heard of Hellenic academic and research
institutions Hong Kong post Hong Kong
post office seems trustworthy yeah so
there's a lot of and then like CNN I see
is one which is like is that still in
here maybe maybe they got rid of it and
then some of them are just have these
numbers and you don't even know you have
to go in yeah trying to internet Network
Information Center Evy certificates
route I I don't I actually really don't
trust them to endorse there we go
okay it's gone solved it solve the
distributed internet trust problems but
oh yeah well I might get I might get
invalid certificate errors for some
Chinese sites now I don't go to many
Chinese um anyway so so that's the the
basic idea of certificate authorities
and this started in like mid-90s when
they wanted to make public key
infrastructure for secure websites one
of the problems is how do you know like
so you've got oh we didn't talk about
diffie-hellman or maybe I mentioned it
but you've got you know public keys
private keys you've got a ways to do
signatures diffie-hellman is a way to do
key exchange so you can have you know if
I know your public key and I give you my
public key we can form a third basically
key that we can then use for encryption
and secure messaging this also works but
how do you know given a key who is on
the other end so that's the idea of
certificate authorities you have this
sort of root of trust and these
certificate authorities sign
certificates in websites and let you
know oh this is the person who you think
it is so for example Google secure
connection really how do I know verified
by Google trust well Google has verified
that Google is trustworthy which is
somewhat circular but but no that's sort
of how it works yeah so Google Google
trust Services is a certificate
authority they ultimately yeah and they
signed off their own certificate for
their own website that's maybe not the
best example there's other what okay The
New York Times they are certified by
Comodo CA who also has had like Komodos
gotten in a lot of trouble for signing
the wrong things so yeah New York Times
does not have an EB cert does I think
Washington Post does so there's also
Evie certs where like you've got now the
Washington Post WP company LLC that's
like an extended validation certain C a
is saying we didn't just check that they
had an IP address
we actually checked that they had some
kind of legal corporate entity and they
sent it on their letterhead and we I
don't know emailed someone in Delaware
to make sure they actually had a company
and this is verified by interest okay so
in trust Komodo those are all gonna be
in here
yeah there's Komodo so you've got these
companies called CAS that have some kind
of agreement with each other there's
sort of these standards where you make
some kind of standards where okay don't
sign the wrong thing if you do we're
gonna delete you and then they all sort
of endorse entities identity usually for
companies there's also stuff now let's
encrypt which does it for free and
without really into in endorsing
anything this whole thing was kind of
sort of felt like it was like the big
scam of like the late 90s because they
made billions of dollars but then again
we got you know boo boo two out of it
right
so yeah Lubuntu was funded by Mark
Shuttleworth who started this one I
believe and made a couple hundred
million Orbitz had some fun you know
eccentric millionaires are what fund a
lot of Technology Development and we got
them so ca's are a lot of the people who
work on Bitcoin and these systems feel
that like the current it's called x.509
it's like the whole the name of this
whole system with these certificate
authorities and I also sort of feel this
is a suboptimal solution in that there's
a lot of problems with certificates
being signed inappropriately it's it
works in a way but it's like not great
so this is a problem so the problem that
these systems like rippln know I have to
deal with are in some ways similar to
the the problem that is solved by CA so
what they do is they say we have a
unique node list we're not actually
endorsing an identity from you know
here's a public key here's a human
company you know here human name
or a company name or something like that
it's we're just saying that they're
unique so it's it's more limited than a
certificate authority it's just saying
we're certifying that these two keys
belong to different people or different
companies which seems easier than the
job of the CA right the CA has to verify
that like the Washington Post is
actually the washing you know the key
whoever's presenting a public key is
actually the Washington Post
so the actual certificate is just
basically here's the pump key here's the
name and then the CA science and you can
look at those and stuff okay so for
synchronization you wait for a majority
of nodes in your unique node list to
sign and if they've signed accept so
there's some recent papers from Ripple
and in order to really get consensus you
need basically a 90 percent overlap in
your unique node list so if I have a
unique node list of Alice and Bob and
Carol and you have a unique node list of
Carol and Dave and we might diverge we
might not agree on the same sort of
chain of transactions because we've got
different people that were looking at
their signatures
we may also with them may all be unique
but if we have different unique people
we're looking to it might not converge
so there's they have a newer paper that
reduces that to 60% ish where the
overlap of what unique nodes everyone
needs to look at is not as large but
still quite large and then the real
question is okay well who provides the
unique node list because how you know
that's not really a job I can do maybe
it is in a way if I know you and like we
do some kind of web of trust thing where
I'm like oh what's your ripple nodes
bump key okay cool I know you and what's
your ripple knows Bucky we meet in
person we sign each other's pub keys we
do the whole PGP kind of thing which you
know I do and the Bitcoin people
actually do this so if I go to so I've
got like a bunch of keys and everyone
signed them and there's like your child
and Kylie and you know all these Bitcoin
people and I'm signing their keys and
they've signed my keys because we meet
in person and do that kind of thing so
we've established not just the unique
node list but we've you know done a CA
free validation of each other's keys you
just meet in person read each other's
keys off so you can do that in practice
it's really nerdy and no one does that
and and it would be cool if we could get
it to be you know easier and maybe
cooler somehow but uh it's been a battle
so who provides the UNL it's probably
kind of obvious well the ripple company
provides the UNL right so when you
download a triple it has a list of
unique nodes those are essentially
de-facto
the the nodes that run ripple and at the
current time they're basically those
nodes are run by the ripple corporation
so a ripple apps stellar
similarly like it it comes with a
default UNL sort of acts like the ca's
right it's sort of how when you start
your computer you've got this this comes
with your OS and you don't really have a
choice
in practice you can I just deleted the
CNNIC one but nobody looks at this stuff
everyone just goes with the default so
that's the problem centralization wife
yes
in ripples at least like a year to go
they may have changed that I know I
think they're trying to but um in
ripples case yeah they ran their own
triple notes they may have some III but
they may now but I know that two years
ago it was just ripple or you know
majority ripple they basically because
they also put in things like they can
sort of freeze funds because ripple got
in trouble with Vinson and they part of
the things they modified their code to
be able to like freeze people's funds if
they did something bad that's definitely
not something that the Bitcoin
developers or even like the etherium
foundation not it's not as direct anyway
the Hearing Foundation sort of did
freeze funds and move them against the
rules of the system in the case of the
Dow but that was in a lot of ways with
support of a lot of the people running a
theory with ripple or they can do it
sort of enough you know without much
brouhaha they just sort of freeze these
funds so it's fast there's no work
involved there's no worry about
propagating blocks and miners getting
advantages but there's also known
identities and so it's sort of more
susceptible to subpoenas and things like
that all the coins in in these cases all
the coins existed at the Genesis block
so in the case of ripple I think is a
hundred billion or something and they
just started with all the coins and sort
of distributive distributed them as they
saw fit
same same with stellar stellar had this
thing where they this party and they
would give them away if you signed up on
Facebook really interesting article
about people in Manila getting thousands
of used SIM cards from the US
registering for new Facebook accounts
selling those Facebook accounts to
people in China the people in China then
registering with stellar as unique
people to get more sellers when you
incentivize things weird things happen
be it either giant warehouses full of
sha-256 chips or giant warehouses full
of you know 20 year old girls in vanilla
putting SIM cards and cell phones all
day yeah I should link to that articles
related so anyway so this is seller 1
and stellar also had this thing where
they were gonna give 20% of the seller
to people who held Bitcoin sort of an
airdrop it didn't I didn't get any from
that it wasn't I was I was sort of
hoping I'm like hey cool airdrop I have
a Bitcoin I'll get some seller I didn't
because you basically had to kytc with
them they said okay you know send in
your you know I don't know if it was a
social security number but send in your
documents and prove that you know you
have these bitcoins and we will credit
some stellar to the same keys and yeah
some people did some people got some
stellar that way but yeah so anyway yeah
we'll put that in stellar is a different
you know it's similar software they
certainly argue about how different they
are stellar had a bog in 2015 I believe
where the sort of consensus broke and
then they said oh it's ripples codes
fault you know this is this is a fault
with all this code base and then ripple
said no no it's because you changed it
you don't know what you're doing
yeah there's a minimum account balance
yeah I mean it's a lot though there's
hundreds of bit so there's enough
forever I mean there's a lot of coins
but yeah I guess the egg but the idea is
not that you have UT EXO's like in
Bitcoin and you sort of make new
addresses you shine the edgy is you have
an address you keep that forever so why
would you have multiple different
addresses that kind of thing anyway so
it's a pretty different system in some
ways you could argue it's one of the
first I SEOs gripple because it's pretty
early they just came up with all their
coins and sort of gave them out and then
started selling them and that's they
continued to do that to this day stellar
is a non-profit which is also sort of
weird because if you make like a billion
dollars off of something that really a
non-profit I don't know you didn't the
organization didn't directly make the
money and then pay it to the employees
or anything but the people who have all
the stellar tokens made a lot of money
interesting sort of ways to do it so I
would I mean sort of they I think both
ripple and stellar argue that that it's
decentralized distributed but I think a
lot of people say well maybe to some
extent but on the spectrum of like
completely decentralized versus you know
one server handles at all it's it's a
lot further on the centralize side and
you know Bitcoin is also kind of
centralized to like we were talking
about on Monday but I would I would
argue these are more so yeah any
questions about riffle stellar pretty
fun okay
the next the big one proof of stake so
this is we've mentioned a little bit its
popular alternative where people really
don't like the proof work stuff
so instead of proving work have the
people who hold coins sign the blocks so
you don't really that sort of bootstraps
in a way your unique node list or your
list of who's who well you don't really
care who they are but if they have coins
you
already if you already have a set of who
owns what coins you can use that to say
okay well the people who own coins now
sign and they presumably have incentives
not to destroy the network they have
coins in um so if you have a given
Genesis block with some kind of initial
distribution you can make it
deterministic I can say I'm just gonna
go with whatever has the most stake
whichever you know whoever that's the
most coins signing off on the next block
and you know given two or three
different histories you can see okay
from the start which has the mo you know
most total stake signing off on these
things so that seems pretty cool here's
some issues stake grinding so for
example let's say you have a system
where the signer of the next block is
determined by the public key nearest to
the previous block hash so for example
okay I'm looking at the current block
hash who gets to sign next well
whoever's key is closest use X or you
know just treat the hash as a number and
treat the pub key as a number and see
which is closest you can do that but the
problem is if the next hash is
determined by the current signer that
current signer can sort of make a new
signature each time and try to make sure
that the block after is also going to be
one where they are again the next signer
and they can make you know a couple
hundred different accounts with their
keys and then keep grinding steak and
this would allow this basically means
that it turns into proof of work because
if you can influence who's going to be
the next block signer yourself by keep
Trump you know keep trying different
ways to sign okay but it's basically
proof of work what instead of hashing
you're signing and then this has
happened in many altcoins one that I
think was kind of interesting was NXT
which is the people who made later when
they said okay well we have a
deterministic signature scheme and so
this can't happen right given a message
and the public key sorry give it a
message in a private key there's only
one signature that can be produce
and this is true like so Bitcoin uses
this
it's called RFC 679 basically then the
random nonce can be deterministically
created from your private key and
message oh the problem is I don't they
realized probably not but you can't
enforce this you don't you know it's a
it's a policy that says okay I'm going
to make a deterministic signature but
given a signature you can't tell if
someone did this or not right so it's
it's up to you to obey this rule but you
can't verify that anyone did it so that
one also quickly devolved into proof of
work and in a tricky way because a lot
of people read the documentation said
okay well there is no way to keep
signing you know you their function that
they wrote there's only one way to sign
you know when you sign a message with
the public key you get a single
signature but people who knew how that
worked under the hood said oh I can
change this code it will still be
accepted as a valid signature even
though I'm using a different signing
scheme so this is one issue state crime
Nick that's there's ways to get around
it so let's say you make it
deterministic you have some way to
enforce that a signer can only create
one message there are certain signature
schemes where you can verifiably make
sure that a single key can only make a
signal signature on a message other ways
to do it is to say have this big lead
time where the people who are signing
the next block are determined by entropy
created days or weeks ago so it's hard
to know what's going to happen in a week
because it's you know a long period of
times worth of entropy going into it
okay there's another issue with prove
mistake call nothing at stake so yeah so
improve of work this happens right this
happens just by accident where okay
there's a block and then two people are
minding on top of it oh they both got
this
and then sometimes even this that's
almost never happens in Bitcoin but
where you just randomly get
to sort of split chains coming out at
the same time but then this happens
right someone builds on this one okay
you get rid of those two and that's just
because you know this is a random
process you can mine on whichever you
want one of those was gonna happen first
you can lie on both you can split your
hash power if you have a billion hashes
per second you could say well I'll do
500 million here and 500 million here
you can equivocate it's sort of
equivocation that way but one of them
will finish first with you know very
high probability so eventually this
happens and then everyone just starts
building off this zero zero three broom
stake so this happens also notice so
this happens but then this happens and
then this happens and then it just keeps
going because why not sign both right I
don't I don't know which one's gonna win
right as a proof of stake sort of minor
or Staker I don't really know which
one's gonna win which is the same case
improve work improve work I just flip a
coin and pick right I don't know what's
gonna win I think in Bitcoin the default
is go with the one I saw first because
maybe whatever it doesn't matter who
wins right if I basically I win
whichever I pick if I'm the next one
making block I went but what I don't
want is I don't want to be this zero
this uh what I don't want to be in proof
of work is I don't want to be OA wait
right I don't want to be the last one to
make a block and then something else
comes out here so if I see you know I'd
rather be Oh Oh F - but you don't know
here right so you just pick one okay
well um improve mistake you don't have
to worry about that I'll just build both
right it takes me no work to sign so I
just sign off on both of them and make
parallel chain and then everyone just
keeps doing that because if I pick one
I might be wrong if I pick both I can't
be wrong so this is a problem called
nothing at stake like you have no risk
here you're not actually doing any work
might as well just keep going yeah
faced with two blocks one I'm both so
the mitigations one of the ideas early
in aetherium was okay this thing called
slasher where if you can prove that a
signature from a different chain you
know so the idea is on chain oo a3 wait
sorry on this chain you say hey look
this guy equivocated you set it off on
two blocks one of which one of which
exists in my history that I can point to
one of which doesn't exist in my history
but I can provide that signature I can
say look here's two signatures at the
same block height but from the same
person what they're signing different
things
let's not invalidate this block but
let's take all the rewards from the
person who signed okay so yeah this is
called flasher I believe in aetherium
like 2014 dude they were sort of saying
hey we're gonna do a prove mistake and
then they sort of tried all these things
and sort of oh it's kind of it's not
trivial let's start with proof of work
and then we'll move to proof mistake
later and that's currently their plan so
this was one of their early algorithms
their early ideas there's also issues
with the mitigation because maybe maybe
it's hard to get this proof into the
blockchain because the the miners or
thus takers are the ones who determine
what gets in and what doesn't and so
they certainly could say look if you
provide so it's the this is if the
person who created this block then sees
in this block that there is a slasher
proof where hey I just now proved that
you equivocated and destroy your account
well the person who signed this doesn't
build on this and instead Forks off and
builds their own right why would I
continue to mine on a chain where I just
lost all my money so there's there's all
sorts of weird you know
and there's mitigation through that so
it's a little bit whack-a-mole where
there's all these weird problems and you
have to sort of try to fix them and then
fixing them introduces new weird things
so there's a lot of people working on it
yeah
long range of taxes is another big one
let's say you go back to the Genesis
block and you rewrite history in Bitcoin
you can also do this it's just really
hard right you could say I'm gonna get a
bunch of miners rewrite all nine years
of bitcoins blocks and we know exactly
how long that will take
there's a simple has a nice graph of it
I think and sometimes it's not very long
sometimes it's actually pretty easy to
do that hash ray this wait yes Bitcoin
network proof of work equivalent days
that's this year this is since the
beginning where what this means is okay
given the current hash rate in Bitcoin
how long would it take to rewrite the
entire history of Bitcoin because the
hash rate goes up right and sometimes it
goes up in so this is the all-time hash
rate it basically always looks like this
because it's exponential so if you look
at it three years ago pretty much the
same the and then this is a log chart so
this actually does show some interesting
like detail where okay this is when the
GPUs came out this is when nothing much
happened in 2012 this is when Asics came
out and then sort of keeps going up and
this is log scale where each number is
so big but so when you have these really
sharp up ticks like in mid-2010 the
current power of the network is so high
that's probably corresponds to this the
lowest point there because that's the
steepest slope where I don't know what
this is a week you could rewrite the
entire history of Bitcoin in a week and
destroy
everyone's currency you know and have
all the coins herself if you had enough
power and under your control you
probably do so and today it sits at
around 200 a little less than 200 so a
little over six months where if you
devoted all the current hash power you
could rewrite all the previous history
still six months it's a lot and it's
interesting how this changes this is I
guess when the Asics first came out so
that is an issue in proof of work that
can happen it's not clear what would
happen would the Bitcoin software like
the software at least in theory the idea
is if something like that happens where
there's a reorg that spans nine years
well you know you know extend this out
to 500,000 say okay all the stuff you've
been dealing with the last nine years
it's out we've got this new history now
with one person holding all the money
presumably the software will do that
probably or oral does crash or something
it's sort of seen as like well if
there's a reorg that spans also you know
weeks or months like the whole system's
broken kind of but probably you know so
this is this is an issue for Bitcoin but
it's it's a big issue in prove mistake
because it seems possibly more feasible
right in in Bitcoin there have been
times it's like whoa a week yeah that's
beautiful whereas right now it's like
okay it would take all the hash power in
existence maybe seven or eight months so
that means that Bitcoin would just halt
for seven months and then you'd see this
reorge happen it seems and also you'd
need you it assumes 51% of the miners
are doing this however approves take it
might not be that expensive especially
if you can get old keys so if you've got
the keys from the Genesis block in your
occurrence in this proof of State
currency you can rewrite a history from
those with different transactions
so yeah so a lot of times the solution
is okay well delete all keys and assume
50% honest that's tricky because old
keys can be sold and people have been I
know that people have asked like hey can
I buy your old aetherium keys why do you
want these
well mistake happens they might be worth
something currently proof of you know
currently if you have keys that are for
addresses or accounts that don't have
any money anymore
it's not very useful but possibly can be
sold yeah so you checkpoint it so
basically to prevent long-range attacks
the developers usually in github will
just say okay well the the block height
Nina the block hash here is this and so
you can tree or debuff for that but then
what's the mechanism for that if it's
the developers just sort of sticking in
a checkpoint that's not really
decentralized
okay well that's even more sort of not
very decentralized if you've now got a
you know a pub key hard-coded into the
code which then calls out to somewhere
and says okay what what's the correct
block to be on and then that key signs
something so go here okay
that's yeah that's pretty centralized so
these this is this is one that I think
is it's hard right because and before
these things happen it's easy to
businesses like this is crazy that's
never gonna happen
who's gonna go back and you know buy up
all these old keys that people were
supposed to have deleted people probably
did delete them you know you can't
assume if they haven't and even if they
did and you made this big reorder well
everyone would know in practice that
that's not the right chain similar to
our if there's a nine year block reorg
and bitcoin everyone would know okay
come on we we all knew what the blocks
were well yesterday you can't just tell
me there's this entirely new history
today and in practice that's probably
true right if there was a nine year
block reorg and Bitcoin I probably
people wouldn't deal you know would just
ignore it
similarly in these systems probably they
would ignore it but it's it's harder to
it's harder to reason about in these
systems I think but anyway so proves
take there is a bunch of coins that use
it in a lot of cases they sort of have
centralization that sort of hidden in
certain ways I like the term Greg
Maxwell came up called trust laundering
it's not money laundering it's stress
laundering like you you sort of move
where you're trusting and trying to hide
it
yeah so so a very common pat this also
deals with okay who gets the initial
coins because they have an enormous
power over the system so very common for
alt coins less so now I think was start
with proof of work then transition to
proof mistake they still do they still
not as much right so you just do er c20
yeah but you it used to be like
2014-2015 a lot of the coins would be
okay proof-of-work for the first month
two months whatever it was with some
weird algorithm and comodo gravity well
and all sorts of weird stuff and then it
would switch in a certain point to proof
of steak so that proof work period
builds out the list of who owns what in
a sort of provable way and then from
there you can use proof of steak because
you've got a fairly hopefully fairly
well distributed set of who owns one ya
know something still do this and some
things have hybrid where you still have
to do work each block but depending on
how much steak you have depending on how
many coins you have you have to do less
work i think d cred is something like
that that actually can make sense
because you still got work and you could
mix them in ways that sort of negate
some of the downsides of both
distributed there no sorry delegated
proof of steak
well signing requires you to actually do
something and be online so in a lot of
proof of state currencies very few
people actually stake because they don't
care and they leave money on the table
sure but like they don't want to run
their own node they don't want to deal
with this stuff they just buy that keep
it on exchange or maybe keep it on their
own computer so instead you can endorse
a leader by signing with your coins and
saying hey I'm not going to actually
sign off on blocks but I'll sign off on
a different key who now can sign on my
behalf and so this can be called like
super nodes master nodes and then is it
peer to peer or is a client server is
what sort of it becomes so the the
current one that's pretty popular is
called yose where I think they're doing
this kind of thing and they're like well
there's twenty twenty computers that run
the network and you can endorse one of
them and they'll give you some kind of
profit back or something and you need
like a million dollars to run one of
these computers because it's gonna be
super powerful and do free transactions
that way so this gets pretty far into
client-server territory where you're not
up here
you're just the client and you ask them
what's going on
which in many cases works right that's
but then again it's not quite as
interesting because that sort of the
system we already have the banks so but
in a lot of cases yeah that's what
people want
I sort of joke that I should just make
one called central coin where there's
just a nice server and it just keeps
track of who owns what and then like
have a nice ego and people will use it
anyway so that's distributed proof
mistake
okay so broomstick in general it's hard
to resolve conflicts using only the
system itself proof work has this really
nice property where it's taking
something from the external world be it
you know CPU time get chips and using
that to sort of get a sort of dead
reckoning on the system itself that's
nice
proof mistake the really difficult part
is it's a closed system you're trying to
resolve conflicts within the system
using no external data that's really
hard
another problem people complain about is
that the rich get richer I you know
agree it's a problem kind of sucks but
you know a broom work is the same I
don't feel like any of these systems
will change the inherent sort of Pareto
distribution of wealth in the universe
that just seems to be how things work be
cool if everyone had the same on the
money I guess maybe but I don't think
yeah and then it relies on different
assumptions so the assumption in bitcoin
is like 51% of miners can destroy the
system so in some cases people say well
you assume 51% honest in Bitcoin kind of
it's more like 51% rational in Bitcoin
you you could have miners with 51%
attacked the system but they make more
money by doing the right thing um so
there are certain cases in prove mistake
where honesty is not as profitable and
if honesty is not profitable well maybe
there's a lot more incentive to be not
honest in the terms of the system
whereas a Bitcoin it's like you've got
this nice system where it seems like the
honesty is not just enforced by people
trying to be nice it's enforced by
people being greedy which is seems more
common than
being nice in the world so there's tons
of research and prove mistakes um that's
pretty interesting but if ever I'm not
super hopeful but the thing is it works
until it doesn't and so it's it's really
hard to show security like under what
different attacks so you what I would
worry about is you've got this proof
mistake system seems to be working and
then something weird happens and it's
sort of revealed as oh actually this was
a lot more centralized than it seemed to
be which is also a worry improving any
questions proved mistake yes a lot of
coins the majority of the coins are held
on different exchanges and so that means
the exchanges would possibly be able to
then stake and get some kind of revenue
yes yeah and so that that's also an
issue that there's all different sort of
ways to mitigate and you know you can
say oh I'm in an exchange but I get to
sign and sort of delegate my stake to
someone else and then I get some kind of
revenue sharing from that but yeah it's
also tricky how do you incentivize it in
terms of how much new coins get issued
to the people staking if it's zero then
there's no real incentive to do it you
could have a lot of different change
boards if it's very high then it's like
very you know Genie Genie net curve goes
way crazy because the rich really get
Richard because the more coins you have
you have like an enormous amount of
revenue so you sort of need a balance
there that's also a bit difficult
economically that's also a problem and
proof-of-work I feel like one of the big
issues with Bitcoin is half the coins
came out in the first four years we're
like hardly everyone anyone was aware of
it and that makes people not want to
adopt the system because it's like well
wait you guys just got all this coin for
basically free use like running your
computer in like 2011 I'm not gonna be
part of that system so I sort of feel
like it would been nicer if it was more
of an s-curve and less of a log curve
because then maybe it would like ramp up
in like 2015 and then lots of points
were coming out but anyway that's so
like a ripple or stellar sort of an
extreme case of that where all the coins
were initially Kate you know made by one
entity and so to me I'm like I don't
want these like that's that's your money
like you just made it up yourself
there's sort of a like I don't know it
just feels like kids being like I have a
bazillion dollars and I write a
bazillion dollars it's like okay well
you just wrote that like I don't not
gonna honor that anyway okay so Bruce
take kind of interesting proof of space
there's a bunch of ideas here some of
them space coins basements was some
people here I know Bram Cohen who is the
author of BitTorrent right he made
BitTorrent whatever and
he's now working on some of these kind
of things he's working on a proof of
space coin called Chia and the idea is
you know it's still similar to proven
work but you're using some kind of
memory or storage space rather than your
CPU and the idea is the benefit as well
maybe it doesn't use as much electricity
and also from talking to Bram with his
he's saying there's much more sort of
dead storage space than dead CPU so
every computer has a CPU but like see if
you hear is not that powerful it can't
really compete with Asics but lots of
people have empty hard drive space and
you might have a terabyte of empty hard
drive space and you know 1 terabytes as
good as another
and it's also empty is what you need
because you need to fill in space for
these systems and so if you're like well
I'm AWS I've got you know tons of hard
drives right but people are using them
so you're not able to then just like
fill it in for these kind of systems
well to some extent they do have a lot
of slack and we can probably do but
several ideas some are pretty cool so
one example that this is sort of an
example idea it's not fully fleshed out
but to give you an idea so you buy a 10
terabyte drive ok you pre-compute 100
billion key pairs and this takes a long
time and this is work right you're doing
100 billion computations of coming up
with a random private key multiplying by
GE getting the pub key and you store it
in a key value store like a database
level DB or something on your hard drive
and the key is the bump key and the
value is the private key so you remember
your key pairs but you've sorted it in a
way so that you can quickly go through
the pump keys alright so you have like
logins search time some kind of binary
tree whatever it is in your database and
so then the idea is to create the next
block you want the key closest to the
current block hash consign so a valid
proof of work you have some threshold
maybe a valid proof of work is whoever
you know whoever's got a key that's very
close to this they're able to sign and
those keys do not exist
the network prior to the signing
procedure they exist just hidden on
people's hard drives and so the idea is
you could just try to keep computing
keys till you find one and then sign
with it and that would just make it
completely proof-of-work
so it is performed and then you can use
that free computed proof of work later
on and possibly multiple times in
practice it's not going to be multiple
times because you've got 100 billion and
you're never gonna like use the same key
twice the idea is everyone knows this
right so you have trillions quadrillions
however many keys out there that
everyone is generated and every block
that comes out someone will say ah I've
I you know was lucky and I made a key
that can now sign the next block
so it's work but it's amortized over
weeks months years and it's basically
how fast you know how big is your
storage if you have a lot of storage you
can pre-compute a lot of this stuff and
then use it so it's kind of a cool
system we'll see there's sort of other
asterisks is that it actually gets a
little more a little more complex
because you need some timing mechanisms
as well but I think it's it's a cool
idea
hard drives then maybe get more
expensive instead of graphics cards
getting more expensive I don't know but
the idea is like yeah you use the work
but later on so any questions about that
one cool there's there's a spaceman it's
a cool paper about how to do this
cryptographically and then she is
another one doing this kind of idea I
sort of like it because it doesn't
really change the assumptions of proof
of work right it's it is still a form of
proof of work but instead of burning
electricity you're using hard drives you
sort of already have that right like
there's server farms where they're just
storage farms and they just have tons of
hard drives so that's already a thing
I guess I guess the idea is the economy
the the economies of scale are not quite
as bad in that hard drives are already
basically optimal at doing this and if
you can make a system that's better at
doing this you've just made a better
hard drive which hey great you made a
better hard drive everyone can use it
so I guess the idea is it's not as
specific cuz it's just hey store a bunch
of data and then see quickly through it
so okay once you generate this you okay
generating this is compute pop right you
need to populate your tent area bright
right but that might only take a few
hours right to make a hundred billion
key pairs guessing less than a day right
yeah and so and you can do that in
parallel so you make it and then once
you've made it you leave it there and
then you're gonna be able to mine with
that forever something you're gonna I
think the the hard drive cost is much
higher than the cost to fill it right
because a 10 terabyte hard drives gonna
be like 200 bucks but you and you can
fill with it with a cheap CPU you can
fill a 10 carbohydrate I have 10
terabyte hard drive every few hours so I
think that like so yeah the the CPU is a
is a factor but I think it's gonna be
smaller than
yeah this is just a seek right
and this any even a crummy hard drive
you just read through your binary
trainer like Oh found it so you look at
okay here's the current block - what do
I have that's close
seek - that on my drive nope not gonna
win this one okay let someone else do it
or you know you see can you find it hey
cool I can find yeah so there so that's
in Chia they sort of add this time
component which I'm not 100% clear on
how it works it's changed a little bit
but you want so the the idea of a time
beacon is you want some function that
cannot be parallelized so that if you
have 100 computers doing it it's not
going to be any faster than one computer
doing it so basically whoever's got the
fastest single CPU will always win this
and that can be sort of a time beacon
for these space things
I mean if you have like tons of hard
drives and you want it like you know
tons of key values and you just want to
find one or find the closest match like
you can do that in log n time even over
a whole data center like you know Google
like you just search and it's like hey
it comes up in like a fraction of a
second so that's that's doable it's you
know you need so you need good software
and you need like a good infrastructure
to do it but I think it's doable
it scales pretty well I think but yeah
it has the same issues where like you
just end up with people buying a whole
bunch of hard drives and like what are
the economies of scale there there's
arguments that it might be better than
the economies of scale with like Asics
that we've heard about on Monday maybe
not I don't know most will see if this
takes off I don't it's like fairly new
it's it's an idea that's been talked
about for a few years but
okay well so there's there's different
it seems like it it seems like one of
the more interesting sort of there's
school math and cool crypto involved
okay so work but amortized so perennial
MIT favorite iota they use a just
directed acyclic graph and now a chain
is also a - you know dag because it's
directed there's no cycles and it's a
graph but it's a pretty simple one but
the idea is have multiple multiple
parents right so if you have a block
instead of just pointing to one you
could say well now this can happen in
Bitcoin right well you've got two blocks
postponing the same thing but this
cannot happen in big where are you
saying oh I'm coming off and I'm
referring to both of these but in a
directed acyclic graph you can do that
so if p.m. actually does this I think
Joe Joe when I was mentioning that and
so what happens is you sort of endorse
one as the correct one and one is the
uncle so you're saying no this is the
real one but I also saw this one and
give this one a little bit of money
right maybe not the whole reward they
were hoping for but they get something
and so then something like iota says
okay we have lots and every node points
to two previous and so you get this
whole map they can even point to
different heights so I can point to here
and here I don't really know why you do
this I guess so there's some ways it can
reduce latency right so one of the
trade-offs in bitcoin is 10 minute block
time seems fairly arbitrary it's kind of
slow latency people don't like late in
these latency because they have to wait
fine the more important metric I think
is that it leads to minor centralization
and minor pools because if there's only
one hundred forty four blocks a day
which like in Bitcoin if you have a
million of the hash power of the network
you're just never going to find anything
right if you're just mining on your own
over the course of a year you're
probably not going to find a single
block and you'll avoid all of that
effort so instead you join a pool and
try to you know pool with other people
to distribute those rewards however if
there's like an aetherium block every 15
seconds and there's you know millions of
blocks that come out if you have a
millionth of the hash power you might
find a block the blocks have smaller
rewards but it's like you know chopping
it up more finally is a nice way to do
it so like pee to pool which you work on
it's a sort of way to try to make that
and it's important to get it more
decentralized but it's hard yeah yeah
yeah pee to pool sort of does this and
as a layer on top so it could help Lane
see and then it could help reduce the
amount of orphans in the blocks in the
block chain which then helps minor
centralization so that does it is there
are interesting ideas for it but it
doesn't help scalability at all right it
actually hurts scalability because now I
have to keep track of all these things
instead of just one chain and I'm gonna
have to keep track of all the data
anyway if I've got the UT Exocet I can't
just ignore parts of it so doesn't help
fail ability at all and in the case of
iota their custom ternary hash functions
also don't help much either so that was
what we wrote about last year they made
all their own weird stuff so there there
are interesting ideas between directed
acyclic graphs but it feels like when
they when they say hey this is more
scalable I get very suspicious because
like it doesn't seem to help scalability
it does possibly help some other things
so also in the case in iota the idea is
well they don't call it this but it's
it's the equivalent of saying every
block must have one and only one
transaction the transactions themselves
have proof work on them
and they point to each other which
basically is the same as you know blocks
have one transaction and you do the work
yourself instead of paying a miner to do
it I think that's not a great deal and
they say that that means there's no fees
I think it's kind of there's still fees
because you're just doing the work
yourself
I think that's equivalent to saying
there is a refrigerator at Home Depot
that doesn't use electricity so hey it's
electricity free but there's a crank on
the back and you have to crank it to
make the refrigerator cold yeah you
could make a refrigerator that way I
don't think people would want it you're
still doing the work you just have to
crank it instead of plugging it in so
the idea of like you don't have to pay
miners a fee to get into a block cuz you
just mind the block yourself or in this
case you mind the transaction yourself
doesn't see my usable anyway so I Otis
fun there we've talked about them a
while ago okay last one that's fun a
group of idle an old idea that I wrote
up four years ago almost it probably
doesn't actually work that well but a
lot of these things don't work that even
if it works it would just move the Cox
from up x2 capex but what you do is you
prove that you're not mining and you get
paid and the other fun thing about this
is it sort of led to some of the ideas
in Lightning Network so the idea is in
Bitcoin the difficulty adjusts so the
blocks come out every ten minutes right
every two thousand sixteen blocks you
look at the timestamps adjust the
difficulty so new miners coming in make
it harder for the existing miners so if
you're a miner you really don't want
anyone else to start joining this
network in mining you really like it as
it is so if you you have the first Asics
you're good
and you don't want everyone to come in
and this is why so many people by mining
equipment and lose money because they
look at the current difficulty and they
say hey here's this device here's how
much electricity uses how many coins it
generates this is profitable I'm gonna
buy this thing and what they don't
realize this is by the time they
actually get it or maybe a few weeks
later the difficulty is like doubled and
now it's making half as many coins for
the exact same amount electricity so
yeah and that's a fairly unique property
of Bitcoin that's not the case and say
gold mining or other extractive
industries there's some kind of curve in
in gold mining where if you pay twice as
much money to like have twice as many
people dig holes and mine gold you won't
get twice as much gold maybe you only
get 10% more gold but you will get some
more right and if you you know drill for
oil
you pay twice as much you'll get some
more but yeah in Bitcoin two times the
mining leads to 1x the coins mind right
there is zero marginal product product
of labor in this system which is weird
and counterintuitive and like doesn't
really exist in normal life
most things like if you know most things
have some kind of sublinear curve where
yeah the first low-hanging fruit you
know if you're mining coal and you start
in Pittsburgh and it's just sitting
there on the hill and you're like hey
that was easy and then eventually you
have to start you know open pit mines
and digging holes and it's expensive and
you you know don't get as good but you
still if you double your effort you're
gonna get some extra stuff out then
again there might be cases and I'm sure
in economics where like eventually goes
negative where if you continue adding
two members to an organization
eventually they're just like deadweight
it may make it less efficient or
something but in a Bitcoin it doesn't
matter how much you mind you always get
the same number of coins so the the
obvious thing there is well we should
all just stop mining and then we'll have
zero electricity usage and we'll still
get the same
yeah however good the science is you
just get one developer so okay so let's
say there's two miners and let's focus
more and each mining with two gigawatts
and they both think we'll wait if we
both turned our mining down five percent
we'd still get the same amount of coins
but we'd be using five percent less
electricity we should have a meeting
maybe some kind of cartel so this is
sort of OPEC right this is a car this is
a classic cartel if we all restrict our
output we can raise prices and reduce
our costs in Bitcoin it's like the
perfect cartel environment because if we
all reduce our output we get the same
output sort of right if we all if we all
turn down mining 50% we all still get
the same number of coins the network
still works fine maybe nobody even knows
we're doing this this is like ideal of
Part L scenario problem for cartels
generally is that cartels are hard to
maintain especially when there's not a
lot of trust because there's so much
profit in defecting and like going
against the rules a good bit of the
cartel and OPEC has this all the time
where one of the OPEC countries says no
we're just gonna pump a bunch of oil and
sell it because everyone else reducing
their output raises the prices and now
we can sell more with high prices so in
this kind of system if all the miners
said hey let's all turn down 50% the one
miner who then mines at full blast is
gonna make a lot of coins so this is the
problem in Bitcoin nobody trusts anyone
right so the solution here is trustless
collusion and I in the papers like well
is a collusion or cooperation it was
sort of mean the same thing and close in
just a bad word for cooperation
cooperation is good okay so the basic
system is a pay Alice pays Bob not to
mine so first the thing Alice needs to
prove that Bob can mine because
she doesn't want to pay Bob but if Bob
doesn't have any mining capacity that
he's taking offline
she only wants to pay Bob for you know
having the ability to mine and then not
doing it
so a posts a block header and a
specified time and says okay be mine for
10 seconds and give me like your hundred
best shots right so you can so in
Bitcoin you have this like fixed
difficulty and you just say okay
anything above anything's right below
this block hash is valid but you could
make one where you say hey give me your
best hundred and I can then extrapolate
or you know interpret from that what
your hash rate is you can get pretty
accurate in them so they have to do some
work right Bob does some work but for a
brief period and I don't know ten
seconds you don't you don't want latency
to be an issue so maybe 10 seconds maybe
a minute whatever some some small amount
of work to prove that they have the
capability to do the work they respond
with that analysis validates that says
okay
you've got X amount of work capacity
Allison creates a - of - multi-sig
transaction and sends one Bitcoin to
this address and builds two transactions
with Bob this is sort of like how like
net network looks lightening channels
but this predates it by a year - the
idea is you've got this funding and then
you've got two transactions they're both
signed by both parties and held by both
parties although in practice the one
that pays out to Alice Bob doesn't
really need to store he doesn't like it
and the one that pays out to Bob Alice
doesn't need a store but the idea is
they have conflicting lock times so in
the in the transaction header you can
have a lock time say okay this
transaction is only valid after this
point so the one that pays Alice is
height plus 144 so the current height of
the blockchain plus 144 well that should
take about a day right if blocks come
out every 10 minutes 144 blocks is one
day for Bob Bob gets the coin with the
current lock time plus 24 hours so in
Bitcoin you can specify either unix time
or block height and I think everything
above 500 million is a time everything
below 500 million is interpretive and
the height
which means the full system runs out in
like a couple thousand years so so that
this is a race right there's two
transactions one of them can be
broadcast first
depending on how fast blocks come out so
if Fox come out very quickly this will
be valid first 144 blocks maybe it only
takes 20 hours and these hundred
forty-four blocks have come out and
Alice can post this transaction and get
all of our money back yet her one coin
back
however if blocks come out slowly and
after 24 hours only a hundred and twenty
blocks have come out
Bob can post this transaction first and
it will be valid and confirmed and Bob
gets the coin so now Bob's incentives
are well I I'd like a hundred forty four
blocks to take longer than 24 hours
because then I'll get this coin and Bob
has the means to influence this right
Bob's a minor so Bob can say well I'll
just mined less and if I mine such that
it you know in 24 hours only 130 blocks
come out I get the coin cool right if
blocks them up fast on the other hand
Alex yes their money back so alice has
no real risk here that Bob will run away
with the money without doing his part of
the job so Bob can slow down his mining
in order to get the bounty coins if
Alice sort of estimates incorrectly how
much profitability bob has Bob just
doesn't do you know just Bob just keeps
mining Alice gets their money back the
this collusion didn't occur at very
little cost right Bob had to prove a
little bit there's some coordination
costs but like basically nobody loses
the money so Alice can put whatever
bounty she thinks is you know beneficial
to her okay I'll pay you three coins not
to mine as much and you can chop this up
you can have like a lot of different
smaller transactions and sort of make a
curve a lot you know if you mind a lot
less I'll tell you more things like that
yeah so that's the idea of I'm improving
vital it doesn't all the product it
feels like it might happen to some
extent like long term it feels sort of
like you know nuclear weapons where like
everyone's got
but like they don't really use them they
just sort of threaten so it feels like
mining could be that kind of thing where
well we've all got all this mining
capacity but we just sort of threatened
each other with it and we don't really
mind uh because the mining is actually
really expensive and it's just a threat
of mining that you need and and if
someone tries to do say a 51% attack and
reorg the existing mining infrastructure
can spin up and say oh no you thought
you were 51% you are actually 5.1
percent and we're 90 percent offline we
all come back online and and reaaargh
you out it's an interesting I mean I
think it's a kind of a fun idea in
practice it doesn't work now because
it's mostly capex so this doesn't help
if your main constraint is building the
chips which it sounds like it still is
like from David's talk on Monday right
yeah you need to get electricity sure
but also a really big problem is getting
a supply of all these chips and so and
this would just exacerbate that this
would make it so that I don't even need
electricity I just get the chips I don't
really care how much I'm paying
electricity because most of the time my
chips it off I just need to occasionally
prove I have them and have the ability
to mine with them so it wouldn't solve
the problem of proof work in terms of
people spending tons of money on it
but it would move it towards okay less
electricity usage more fabrication plant
usage is that a good thing I don't I
don't know my in certain cases it may be
that it saves people money it may be
that like hey if we can collude in this
way it actually we save money and then
we can we can use it to build more hash
power so this might happen I'm not as
convinced I was sort of convinced like
in 2014 I'm like oh I think this is
gonna happen I also thought that it
would become predominantly effects in
like 2015 or 16 and it just did not even
close so who knows okay so in general
lots of new ideas out there proven work
does seem to work
but I think one of the big issues is
it's not really compatible with the sort
of Kurzweil Roddenberry future idea I
don't know if anyone read like Ray
Kurzweil like age of spiritual machines
there's it's sort of like this future II
like AI is gonna make everything great
and we're all gonna live forever and
computers are gonna be like our best
friends and we're gonna take over the
universe and Gene Roddenberry of Star
Trek is is sort of a popular not quite
as crazy maybe justice crazy view of
that we're like we're all gonna you know
in Star Trek they don't have money they
just sort of explore the universe and
make the world a better place and stuff
like that and it's like cool and there's
a lot of people who are into technology
in research who are you know maybe not
consciously but identify with these
ideas that like yeah we're making the
world a better place we're making
computers are gonna help people and it's
gonna be great and I think one of the
issues with Bitcoin and proof-of-work is
it doesn't fit into that right it's sort
of dystopian in a way and then it's like
wait we're gonna have like giant server
farms performing sha-256 for the next 50
years like how what does how does how
does the benevolent AI fit into this
system so so that's one of the reasons
people like I the prove vital idea was
my I was at University of Virginia and I
Miche a lot who's now at Northeastern he
was like I hate Bitcoin because the
whole point of sha-256 is that you can't
find collisions that was the design like
there's no you know collision resistant
hash function and now you've built this
giant system which the whole point of
the system is to find collisions like ah
like that's the opposite of what it was
supposed to be and so it was just sort
of like in elegant and ugly and that was
why I'm like well maybe you don't really
have to mind that much and so I wrote
this thing about broom life but anyway
that's one of the issues that people
have with proof work and that's I think
one of the big you know motivating
factors for all this other research into
different consensus algorithms and
further research is required
maybe the interesting thing is a lot of
the people doing proof of work are fine
with it
right so like David Monday he's not
interested in mistake haha despite the
proof of work you know ecosystem being
so crazy he's just like no this is what
I'm doing so none of the miners are
interest I mean you know miners their
job is to mine so they're usually not
interested in proof of steak and and
then Bitcoin in general a lot of it's
like no this seems to work we're okay
with it this is the cost we're willing
to bear but other people want to do
other systems so further research is
required or not but it's happening
there's tons of research into different
consensus mechanisms I would say an
academic research that's like the
biggest thing what I would like to see
more of is more academic research in
proof-of-work
because there's a little bit but there's
all sorts of interesting things with
proof-of-work where it's like oh you
know something like prove vital or
something like the stuff David was
talking about on Monday like there's not
much economics research into this and I
think it's a really interesting question
where you've got like hey I've got a
device that prints money and I want to
sell it to you like how does that work
in terms of economics like how much
should I sell it for how much should I
buy it for things like that um so
there's a lot of new research into new
proof of stake different consensus or
mechanisms economics that way and not as
much into new forms or how proof of work
works which i think is actually really
interesting